[Música]
y ahora sí vamos con nuestro primer
invitado del día el gobierno de Bolivia
promulgó la llamada ley del Oro que fue
aprobada en el parlamento y que
permitirá al Banco Central vender parte
de sus reservas de oro y también comprar
este metal directamente a productores
locales para refinarlo y certificarlo
internacionalmente la medida es un
intento por recuperar la economía del
país en medio de la escasez de dólares
para analizar este tema saludamos a
Gonzalo Chávez Álvarez quien es
economista con estudios doctorales en la
universidad de Manchester y con maestría
en administración pública de la
Universidad de Harvard y maestría en
política económica de la Universidad de
Columbia muchas gracias a ustedes
Gonzalo y Juan Pablo Buenos días también
para usted nuestro periodista económico
para desarrollar esta entrevista Buenos
días Ángela y buenos días bueno Gonzalo
comenzamos Disculpe preguntándole En qué
se diferencia esta normativa de la que
fue promulgada por Evo Morales en 2011
la llamada ley para compra de oro
destinado a reservas internacionales
bueno básicamente la compra antes la
hacía con mi bola la incorporación
minera de Bolivia una agencia Estatal
que el gobierno boliviano ahora lo hará
directamente el Banco Central entonces
esa es la gran diferencia y es
simplemente como referencia histórica
esta agencia con mi gol compró en el
pasado medios de una tonelada ahora el
gobierno pretende comprar por año entre
cinco y diez toneladas de oro de los
cooperativistas mineros que son los
grandes productores de oro en Bolivia
sin embargo hay dudas de que esto
funcione porque es probable que sí le
vendan el oro hay mucha informalidad en
este sector habrá que ver si se acercan
a venderle oro al Banco Central de
Bolivia además no nos olvidemos que van
a pagar en bolivianos al pagar en
bolivianos pues Esto va a llegar a manos
de los cooperativistas mineros que
seguramente harán gastos en bolivianos
pero también necesitan insumos que se
pagan en dólares además en este sector
hay que hay sectores de Chile de Perú de
China que también van a requerir dólares
entonces en la compra de dólares este
entrarán dólares al Banco Central pero
también saldrán dólares saldrán entrarán
oro al Banco Central pero también
saldrán dólares Entonces el resultado
neto es dudoso No y lo que el gobierno
promete ahora es vender más o menos la
mitad de sus reservas internacionales
que estaban en 42 toneladas va a vender
21 eso al mercado y al precio de Mercado
de hoy Son como mil trescientos millones
de dólares que ayudará a aliviará
parcialmente la escasez de Divisas
porque este Bolivia tiene grandes
necesidades Especialmente con
importaciones que por mes llegan a mil
millones
evidentemente las exportaciones
compensan eso pero no han estado
aumentando lo suficiente ya en los dos
primeros meses del año ha habido un
déficit de más de 400 millones de
dólares precisamente gonza Buenos días
con Juan Pablo lucumí hablemos acerca de
la informalidad y de las cantidades de
las toneladas porque el banco de Bolivia
deberá mantener un mínimo se ha dicho de
22 toneladas de reserva de oros y además
tendrá que informar cada cuatro meses al
legislativo de estas reservas y las
operaciones que realice usted hablaba la
informalidad Y si esto se pueda lograr
cuando por ejemplo nada más con los
datos de
la reserva internacionales netas no se
tienen registros actuales el dato más
actuales de febrero Y entonces cómo se
va a manejar esto y para que se tenga en
cuenta las cantidades y las fechas Bueno
eso es justamente lo que vamos a ver el
gobierno ha vuelto un secreto de estado
el nivel de las reservas internacionales
no sabemos exactamente Cuántos son antes
se publicaba semanalmente como usted muy
bien dijo la última información es al
ocho de febrero del 2023 donde habían
tres mil quinientos millones de dólares
eso ha bajado se calcula que algo como
tres mil y estos mil trescientos
adicionales que recibiría el gobierno
aliviaría muy parcialmente las
necesidades de Divisas Por otra parte se
espera que con esta Norma se
transparente un poco el mercado del Oro
porque hay un enorme informalidad en el
mercado del oro y ahora tendrían que los
cooperativistas mineros registrarse con
el Banco Central de Bolivia este decir
dónde producen Cómo producen etcétera Y
eso pues esa sería la condición para
venderle el oro al Banco Central de
Bolivia sin embargo hay dudas de queso
ocurra justamente por el enorme nivel de
informalidad que existe en el sector
bueno Gonzalo algunos parlamentarios
opositores han considerado que esta
medida puede convertirse en lo que han
llamado un cheque en blanco para las
operaciones con las reservas de oro y le
quiero preguntar entonces Cuáles son los
riesgos potenciales que existen con esta
medida
Bueno mira las reservas internacionales
de Bolivia el año 2015 eran quince mil
millones de dólares y el gobierno de Evo
Morales gastó ocho mil seiscientos
cincuenta y entre levo entre los
gobiernos de añes y Arce catacora han
gastado otros dos mil ochocientos dos
tres mil millones de dos el gobierno
boliviano ha tenido que gastar como doce
mil millones de dólares y no ha podido
reponer a la velocidad suficiente las
reservas internacionales del gran miedo
que existe por eso la oposición habla de
un cheque en blanco Es que esto se gaste
nuevamente y de que algunos meses
estemos nuevamente buscando dólares ya
sea de préstamos internacionales o
vendiendo la otra parte que queda de las
reservas internacionales Lamentablemente
esto ocurre porque el déficit público
que es el origen de El la pérdida de
reservas internacionales que es de siete
por ciento del pib este no han habido
cambios ni por el lado de los ingresos
ni por el lado el gastos en cuanto no se
cierre el déficit público este las
reservas internacionales corren el
riesgo de ser simplemente gastadas y no
poder reponerlas y precisamente podemos
hablar incluso del lado un poco positivo
acerca de toda esta medida es que se
habla de un panorama mejor Para Bolivia
en cuanto a los mercados mundiales
porque se va a operar con este metal
cómo será este escenario es de pronto
más seguro como es esta noticia para los
mercados mundiales Y pues el escenario
de Bolivia en la en ese sector mire
parcialmente seguramente las los bonos
bolivianos han subido un poco y estaban
muy bajos habían llegado a la mitad de
su valor no que hasta 50% esta venta del
Oro ha hecho que suba a 60 70 por ciento
pero la situación de préstamos en los
mercados privados Para Bolivia sigue muy
difícil entonces por ese lado es difícil
acceder a nuevos recursos en dólares con
préstamos porque estarían a quince
dieciséis por ciento al año lo cual es
un valor muy alto entonces
la medida parcial va a ayudar en el
cortotísimo plazo sin embargo los
desafíos macroeconómicos continúan
siendo los mismos el gran problema de
Bolivia es que era una potencia gasífera
este exportaba seis mil seiscientos
millones de dólares de gas natural ahora
exporta menos de la mitad tres mil
millones de dólares del de este
energético antes recibía del gas de
renta petrolera de 5.489 ahora recibe
2.289 es decir 3.200 millones de dólares
menos ese es el origen de esta escasez
de Divisas del déficit público es que el
gas que era el oxígeno del modelo
económico pues está en declive
pues mire Muchísimas gracias es Gonzalo
Chávez Álvarez economista invitado de
France 24 muy amable
Muchísimas gracias por la entrevista
Buenos días Juan Pablo Gracias también a
usted y ya lo espero para que hablemos
de más noticias de economía ahora en
pocos minutos vamos a hacer una pequeña
pausa ya regresamos con más de directo a
América quédense con nosotros
[Música]